Effectively integrating new education initiatives
into classrooms is a big challenge.
Social and emotional learning, or SEL, is
no exception.
Research can help, but only when used wisely.
For one thing, researchers favor work
that tends to tell us "what works".
The risk is that such research yields “evidence-based
recommendations” that can give short shrift
to what it takes to make a measure work or
how well a program successful in one place
will translate to another.
Another issue: Some of what we most value
in SEL, like students’ sense of belonging
or their relationship skills, is difficult to measure reliably.
Climate surveys are a start, but they limit
results to a subjective, vague sense of a
school’s progress in improving student wellbeing.
When the evidence is shaky or the research
uncertain, SEL advocates need to face that
fact head-on.
The solution?
Transparency, willingness to draw feedback
from supporters and skeptics, and research
that’s attentive to real-world challenges.
How do you think school's should measure social and emotional learning?
Let us know in the comments. Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.